Pero no es solo en Australia donde se tiene mejor salud que en Gran Bretaña.
Dentro de Gran Bretaña existe un gradiente de salud,
que se denomina mortalidad estandarizada,
básicamente, son las probabilidades de muerte.
Estos son datos de un artículo de hace cerca de 20 años
pero sigue siendo cierto hoy.
Comparando las tasas de muerte 50 grados norte
—esto es el sur, esto es Londres y alrededores—
de latitud y 55 grados...
La mala noticia está aquí, en Glasgow.
Yo soy de Edimburgo. Peores noticias aún en Edimburgo.
(Risas)
Entonces, ¿cómo se explica esta horrible brecha aquí
entre nosotros aquí en el sur de Escocia
y el sur?
Ahora, tenemos información sobre el tabaquismo,
las barras fritas Mars, las patatas fritas... la dieta de Glasgow.
Todas estas cosas.
Pero esta gráfica toma en cuenta
todos estos factores de riesgo conocidos.
Esto es después de tener en cuenta el tabaco, la clase social, la dieta,
todos los otros factores de riesgo conocidos.
Quedamos con esta brecha
de más muertes cuanto más vas al norte.
Ahora, la luz del sol, por supuesto, entra en esto.
La vitamina D ha tenido una gran cantidad de prensa,
y mucha gente se preocupa por esto.
Necesitamos vitamina D. Ahora es un requisito que los niños tomen una cierta cantidad.
Mi abuela se crió en Glasgow,
en las décadas de 1920 y 1930, cuando el raquitismo era un verdadero problema
y se introdujo el aceite de hígado de bacalao.
Este realmente prevenía el raquitismo que solía ser común en esta ciudad.
De niño, mi abuela me daba aceite de hígado de bacalao.
Yo claramente... Nadie olvida el aceite de hígado de bacalao. (Risas)
Pero veamos una asociación: Cuanto más altos son los niveles de vitamina D en la sangre,
menor es la presencia tanto de enfermedades cardíacas como de cáncer.
Parece haber un montón de datos que sugieren que la vitamina D es muy buena para las personas.
Y lo es, para prevenir el raquitismo y otras dolencias.
Pero si se le da a la gente suplementos de vitamina D,
no cambia la elevada tasa de enfermedades del corazón.
Y tampoco hay evidencia de grandes cambios en la prevención del cancer.
Por tanto, yo sugeriría que la vitamina D no es la única protagonista.
No es la única razón para la prevención de las enfermedades del corazón.
Los altos niveles de vitamina D, creo, son un indicador de la exposición a la luz solar,
y la exposición a la luz del sol, mediante procedimientos que voy a mostrar,
es buena contra las enfermedades del corazón.
De todos modos, regresé de Australia,
y a pesar de los evidentes riesgos para mi salud, me mudé a Aberdeen.
(Risas)
Bueno, en Aberdeen, comencé mi formación en dermatología.
Pero también me interesé en la investigación,
y en particular me interesé por esta sustancia, el óxido nítrico.
Ahora, estos tres chicos de aquí,
Furchgott, Ignarro y Murad,
ganaron el Premio Nobel de Medicina en 1998.
Fueron los primeros en describir
este nuevo transmisor químico, el óxido nítrico.
Lo que hace el óxido nítrico es dilatar los vasos sanguíneos,
por lo tanto disminuye la presión arterial.
También dilata las arterias coronarias, por lo tanto detiene la angina.
Lo notable de esto
es que en el pasado, cuando pensábamos en los mensajeros químicos en el cuerpo,
pensábamos en cosas complicadas como el estrógeno y la insulina,
o la transmisión nerviosa.
Procesos complicados con químicos muy complejos
que encajan en receptores igualmente muy difíciles.
Pero he aquí que esta molécula increíblemente simple,
formada por nitrógeno y oxígeno unidos,
es sin embargo, muy importante para [no es claro] mantener baja la presión arterial,
para la neurotransmisión, por muchas, muchas cosas,
y en particular por la salud cardiovascular.
Empecé a investigar y encontramos, de manera muy emocionante,
que la piel produce óxido nítrico.
Entonces no es solo en el sistema cardiovascular en donde surge;
aparece en la piel.
Bien, después de haber descubierto esto y de publicarlo,
pensé, bueno, ¿qué es lo que hace?
¿Cómo se tiene presión arterial baja en la piel?
No es en el corazón. ¿Qué hacer entonces?
Así que me fui a EE.UU, como hacen muchos investigadores,
y pasé unos años en Pittsburgh. Esto es Pittsburgh.
Yo estaba interesado en estos sistemas tan complejos.
Pensamos en que tal vez el óxido nítrico tenía efecto en la muerte celular,
en cómo las células sobreviven y en su resistencia a otras cosas.
En primer lugar comencé a trabajar en el cultivo celular y en el crecimiento de las células.
Por aquel entonces yo estaba usando modelos con "ratones knockout"
—ratones con uno o mas genes desactivados—.
Trabajamos en un mecanismo, en el que el óxido nítrico estaba ayudando a las células a sobrevivir.
Entonces regresé a Edimburgo.
En esta ciudad, el conejillo de indias que utilizamos eran los estudiantes de medicina.
Es una especie cercana a los humanos,
con varias ventajas sobre los ratones:
Son gratis, no hay que afeitarlos, se alimentan solos,
y nadie hace manifestaciones píublicas diciendo:
"Salven a los estudiantes de medicina de laboratorio".
Por tanto son realmente ideales.
Pero lo que encontramos
fue que no podíamos reproducir en el hombre los datos demostrados en ratones.
Parecía que no podíamos detener la producción
de óxido nítrico en la piel de los seres humanos.
Pusimos cremas para bloquear la enzima productora,
inyectamos sustancias. Pero no podíamos bloquear el óxido nítrico.
Y la razón de esto —que apareció después de dos o tres años de trabajo—
es que en la piel tenemos enormes depósitos
no de óxido nítrico, porque es un gas,
y una vez liberado — ¡Puuf! — en pocos segundos se va,
pero puede estar transformado en estas formas de óxido nítrico
—nitrato, NO3; nitritos, NO2; tionitritos,
que son más estables,
y realmente la piel tiene grandes depósitos de óxido nítrico.
Entonces pensamos para nuestros adentros, si sería posible
que la luz del sol activara esos grandes depósitos
y los liberara de la piel,
donde los depósitos son cerca de 10 veces más grandes que lo que está en la circulación.
¿Podría el sol activar esos depósitos hacia la circulación,
y allí en la circulación aportar sus beneficios para el sistema cardiovascular?
Bueno, soy un dermatólogo experimental,
así que lo que hicimos fue pensar
que teníamos que exponer a nuestros conejillos de indias a la luz solar.
Entonces tomamos un montón de voluntarios
y los expusimos a la luz ultravioleta.
Bueno, éstas son como lámparas de sol.
Ahora, fuimos cuidadosos con lo siguiente:
la vitamina D es producida por rayos ultravioletas B
y queríamos separar nuestra estudio del estudio de la vitamina D.
Por tanto usamos rayos ultravioleta A, que no producen vitamina D.
Cuando pusimos a las personas bajo una lámpara
por el equivalente de unos 30 minutos de sol de verano en Edimburgo,
lo que produjimos fue un aumento
en la circulación de óxido nítrico.
O sea que al poner pacientes bajo radiación UV,
sus niveles de óxido nítrico subieron,
y su presión arterial descendió.
No por mucho, a nivel individual,
pero lo suficiente a nivel poblacional,
como para cambiar las tasas de enfermedad cardíaca en el conjunto de la población.
Cuando les dirigimos los rayos ultravioleta,
o cuando los calentamos al mismo nivel que las lámparas,
pero sin dejar que los rayos alcanzaran la piel, eso no sucedió.
Al parecer es una característica de los rayos ultravioleta al alcanzar la piel.
Ahora, todavía estamos recopilando datos.
Hay algunas cosas buenas en esto:
Parece ser que el efecto se acentúa en las personas mayores.
No sé exactamente cuánto.
Uno de los sujetos aquí fue mi suegra,
y evidentemente no sé su edad. (Risas).
Pero ciertamente en personas mayores que mi esposa,
parece haber un efecto más marcado.
Otra cosa que debo mencionar
es que no hubo cambios en la vitamina D.
Esto es independiente de la vitamina D.
Por tanto la vitamina D es buena. Detiene el raquitismo y
previene el metabolismo del calcio, aspectos importantes.
Pero este es un mecanismo independiente de la vitamina D.
Ahora, mirando la presión arterial vemos que
el cuerpo hace todo lo posible
para mantener la presión arterial en el mismo nivel.
Si uno se cercena una pierna y pierde sangre,
el cuerpo reacciona, aumenta la frecuencia cardíaca,
hace todo lo posible para mantener la presión arterial.
Es un principio fisiológico absolutamente fundamental.
Lo que hicimos a continuación
fue estudiar la dilatación de los vasos sanguíneos.
Hemos medido... Este es otra vez,
noten sin cola y sin pelo, se trata de un estudiante de medicina—. (Risas)
Se puede medir el flujo sanguíneo en el brazo
midiendo cuánto se hincha mientras le fluye la sangre.
Y lo que hemos demostrado es que cuando hacemos una irradiación simulada
—la línea gruesa aquí—
Esta es ultravioleta sobre el brazo, se calienta,
pero lo mantenemos cubierto para evitar que los rayos alcancen la piel.
No hay ningún cambio en el flujo sanguíneo, en la dilatación de los vasos sanguíneos.
Pero la irradiación activa,
durante la radiación ultravioleta y por una hora después,
hay dilatación de los vasos sanguíneos.
Este es el mecanismo por el que la presión arterial baja,
por el que se dilatan las arterias coronarias también,
para que el corazón siga suministrando sangre.
Aquí hay más datos sobre los beneficios de los rayos ultravioleta,
o sea de la luz solar, sobre el flujo sanguíneo y el sistema cardiovascular.
Pensamos que habíamos logrado una especie de modelo.
Diferentes cantidades de UV alcanzan diferentes partes de la Tierra en diferentes épocas del año,
así se pueden activar esos depósitos de óxido nítrico,
los nitratos, nitritos, tionitritos en la piel,
y descomponerlos para liberar NO.
Diferentes longitudes de onda de luz tienen diferentes mecanismos para hacer esto.
Se pueden ver las diferentes longitudes de onda de la luz que hacen eso.
Se puede ver que si uno vive en el ecuador, el sol viene directo sobre la cabeza,
y nos llega a través de una capa muy delgada de atmósfera.
En invierno o verano, es la misma cantidad de luz.
Si Uds. viven aquí, en verano
el sol llega directamente hacia abajo,
pero en invierno llega a través de una enorme cantidad de atmósfera,
que abserbe gran parte de la luz ultravioleta
de modo que la gama de longitudes de onda que alcanza la Tierra
es diferente en verano y en invierno.
Por tanto, se pueden multiplicar esos datos
por el óxido nítrico liberado
y se puede calcular cuánto óxido nítrico
se libera en la piel para ir a la circulación.
Ahora, si uno está en el ecuador
—entre estas dos líneas aquí, la roja y la violeta—
la cantidad de óxido nítrico liberado es el área bajo la curva,
es el área en este espacio aquí.
Así, en el ecuador, en diciembre o junio,
se puede liberar grandes cantidades óxido nítrico (NO) en la piel.
Ventura está el sur de California.
En verano, es como en el ecuador.
Es genial, se liberan montones de NO.
Ventura, en pleno invierno, bueno, todavía hay una cantidad suficiente...
Edimburgo en verano, el área bajo la curva es bastante buena,
pero ahí mismo en invierno, la cantidad de NO que se puede liberar
es prácticamente nula, cantidades muy pequeñas.
Entonces ¿qué decimos?
Todavía estamos trabajando en este estudio,
todavía lo estamos desarrollando, lo estamos expandiéndo.
Creemos que esto es muy importante,
Que probablemente esta sea parte de la razón de la gran diferencia de salud entre el norte y el sur de Gran Bretaña
Es de importancia para nosotros.
Pensamos que la piel,..
Bueno, sabemos que la piel tiene depósitos muy grandes
de óxido nítrico así como otras varias formas.
Sospechamos que muchas de ellas provienen de la dieta;
verduras de hoja verde, remolacha, lechuga,
tienen bastante de estos óxidos nítricos que pensamos, van a la piel.
Creemos entonces que están depositados en la piel,
y creemos que la luz del sol los libera.
en donde generalmente tienen efectos beneficiosos.
Se trata de trabajos en curso, pero los dermatólogos...
Quiero decir, yo soy dermatólogo.
Mi trabajo diario es decirle a la gente,"Usted tiene cáncer de piel,
causada por la luz solar, así que no se exponga al sol".
Realmente pienso en un mensaje mucho más importante,
y es que la luz solar presenta tanto beneficios como riesgos.
Sí, la luz solar es el principal factor de riesgo modificable en el cáncer de piel,
pero las muertes por enfermedades del corazón son cien veces más altas
que las muertes por cáncer de piel.
Creo que necesitamos ser más conscientes de ello,
y tenemos que encontrar la relación riesgo-beneficio.
¿Cuánta luz solar es segura?
Y ¿cuál es la mejor manera de ajustar esto para nuestra salud general?
Entonces, sinceramente, muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)